Fidel Castro has ruled Cuba since
nineteen fifty-nine his brother Raul is
in line to be a successor former CIA
Cuba analyst Brian littell looks at the
future of the communist state in his new
book after fidel this talk from books
and books in Coral Gables Florida is an
hour ten minutes evening everyone and
welcome to books and books today we have
the tremendous honor and pleasure of
presenting to you the author of after
fidel the inside story of Castro's
regime and Cuba's next leader mr. Brian
littell he has he will incorporate his
many years of intelligence service and
academic service he has in the pursuit
of the answer to a riddle that I guess
we in South Florida face on a daily
basis and have historically face and
that is what is going to be the line of
succession to Fidel Castro's regime in
Cuba so without stealing his thunder
I'll let mr. littell explain it welcome
board
thank you very much I am really very
pleased to be here and it's it's very
gratifying to see so many of you here
are some old friends some former
students at Georgetown University and I
had some other Don boning and other
people that that I've worked with and
known over the years the the book is
called after fidel for a couple of
reasons neither one of them were my
reasons at first I had a different title
that I was working with but a publisher
thought after fidel would work better
and I think they I think in retrospect
that they're right it has a double
meaning that if any of you have even
read just the prologue you're you're
aware of the double meaning it's a book
about cuba after fidel castro it's it's
it's a book largely about the castro
brothers about raul castro and there's I
don't to my knowledge has never been
anything more than a more than a few
hundred words in length that has ever
been written about Raul Castro in all of
these years he's been defense minister
in Cuba since October 1959 by far the
world's longest-serving defense minister
and you can barely find a hundred words
consecutive words written about him in
any language at any time over all of
these years so in that in that regard
this this book i think is unique so it's
about it's about cuba after fidel Raul
has been the designated successor since
the very first weeks of the revolution
in 1959 so it's it's about the
succession it's about it's about Raul
and what kind of person he is but the
book is the book is also partly memoir
and a lot of it is written in the first
person and in that in that sense the
other meaning of after fidel is that
since since i was a very young CIA
analyst in 1964 i began i was given the
assignment of trying to get under his
skin and under his beard into his boots
into his mind to try to try to
understand to psychology and his
leadership style and to try to develop
some some ways of anticipating
predicting
how he would behave he was such a high
priority for the for them and for the
American administrations in the night
especially in the 1960s so after fidel
refers to to my role in monitoring him
and tracking him in being right behind
him sort of on his heels after him after
him in the sense of tracking or hunting
him i have a very very dubious
distinction that I'm a little
embarrassed to share with you i have
read just about every word this man has
ever spoken in public and he has said
more on the public record than any human
being in history so this is a this is a
fairly dubious distinction isn't it but
but he's fascinated this is a
fascinating extraordinary historical
figure Fidel Castro like him or love him
or hate him I think you've got to admit
this is a man who has left left a deep
deep set of tracks in in the history of
the last the last 50 or 60 years not
just in Cuba but in in all of Latin
America and in in u.s. foreign policy
pigs the missile crisis and and so many
other crises off you know beginning
beginning in 1959 an extraordinary
individual Raul Castro was not quite as
interesting but I think he's
psychologically and emotionally more
complex than Fidel if if if it's hard to
imagine that isn't it but I think of
Fidel and I write about him in the book
as as a Titanic a Titanic individual and
a very insular individual a man a very
limited very constricted emotional and
psychological scope and capability a man
who by his own account on many many
occasions and he has expressed this in a
variety of different ways he has said I
have never had a mentor I have never had
an advisor I have never had a man woman
who influenced me in ways that were
profound and which set me in in certain
important directions I have never had a
mentor almost all of us have had mentors
and almost all of us would admit and be
proud of having had mentors he is proud
of never having had a mentor his
personal autonomy his sensitive personal
and emotional sovereignty is is almost
beyond the imagination of all of us
normal ordinary even even most
extraordinary human beings this is a man
who's never had a boss I mean this is
this is just another way of saying the
same thing he's never had a mentor he's
never had anyone who strongly influenced
him he's never had a boss I I used to
ask my students through them are here
can you think of anybody else any
anywhere in the last hundred or two
hundred years you know other than some
king or death spot who never had a boss
who never had to say yes sir I'll do
that right away I'll get on it you know
just you know just just be patient i'll
get it done for you he's never had a
boss now he he was very dependent on his
father the Spaniard the Spanish
immigrant on Hill costado who supported
Fidel extravagantly Fidel was his by far
his favorite son of many children Fidel
was by far his favorite doted on and and
extravagantly supported by on hill but
Fidel resented his father he resented
his father because he was a peasant it
was almost entirely illiterate and he
was a simple man and Fidel Fidel didn't
really Fidel took from him but but had
resented him Fidel was dependent on the
Soviet leaders through through many
decades and to a considerable extent he
resented them as well and and he taunted
them and he he worked against them in
many ways I I've thought about I've
thought about this this odd this
peculiar distinction of Fidel's that he
never had a boss and I've asked many
many people to try to help me think of
somebody else in that category and we
can't count queen elizabeth i mean
that's she's not a head of she
a head of government you know she
doesn't really make important decisions
the only other the only other historical
figure in modern times who who can who
fits in that category is Lenin the
Soviet the Soviet revolutionary and
dictator Lenin was the only the only
other one who can be said to be fit in
that category Fidel is is he's
complicated but he's emotionally he's a
ver he's in a very very small space but
the book the introductory chapter of the
book opens in Houston Texas if if any of
you have had a chance yet to look at it
it seems like an odd place to begin a
book about the Castro brothers but you
know they in april of nineteen
fifty-nine they spent a day there
together in houston texas and they had a
violent screaming shouting confrontation
Fidel had was in sort of at the tail end
of a weeklong public relations tour of
the United States he traveled up the
east coast from Washington all the way
to Boston with many intermediate stops
and his objective was to convince
American public opinion that he was not
a communist that he was a Democrat that
he was not supporting revolutionary
violence and other Latin American
countries that that he would have
elections in Cuba all of those things of
course were lies but but he wanted to
convince the American public opinion of
all of those things meanwhile Raul back
in Havana is is be lying openly be lying
all of these things that Fidel is trying
to convince the American American public
opinion of Raul then was the more
dogmatic the more radical the more the
more violent of the brothers he was
openly a marxist-leninist infidel Fidel
was not openly he was to some degree
secretly attracted to Marxism they had
that they had a furious confrontation at
the shamrock hotel in Houston it lasted
through much of the night screaming and
yelling at each other and the next
morning they think they emerged and met
the press and were required
and it was the only the only day that
Raul Castro has ever spent in the united
states that one day in april of nineteen
fifty-nine he's never been back he had
never come before and he has he has very
little understanding of the united
states he said almost no direct contact
with with the United States or with
Americans he rarely sees American
visitors in Havana this is very
important is very relevant to how we
assess a rally stone regime if in fact
he takes power after fidel the the
reason i bring up the houston meeting
and the the differences between the
brothers in april of nineteen fifty-nine
is that I i believe it's theirs i
believe there's a very good likelihood
that today they have reversed those
roles that today fidel is the more
dogmatic the more ideologically fixed
and ideologically inflexible of the
brothers it's Fidel who still is most
interested places such a high priority
on revolutionary internationalism just
look at his connections with rakov is
with Ava wat alles in Bolivia with with
other new the new generation the new
breed of Latin American revolutionaries
all of them inspired by Fidel Castro so
fidelis till Fidel is now the more the
more radical in I think in in these
regards I think that Raul maybe if he
were to take power he might prove to be
much more flexible much less dogmatic
than Fidel I I think it's pretty pretty
commonly accepted that Raul is attracted
to the Chinese development model that if
he if raul succeeds Fidel that Raul
would would want to maintain a very very
tough pull the burts off very strenuous
political control in Cuba but that he
favors he favors much broader deeper
economic reforms than then Fidel Fidel
is permitted very little by way of
economic reform and liberalisation and
opening of the economy to free
enterprise China style Fidel was
appalled when he went to China several
years ago he was said to have been just
appalled horrified
frightened by the prospect that Cuba
could ever under under his control could
ever go in that direction but Raul has
also been to China and I i I'm convinced
and many others as well that that's the
model that charge that Raul would like
to pursue so a raul Easter regime could
very well be very very different from
from the feed Alista regime we've known
for 47 years I I spoke to and I I spoke
to Elena Fernandez Fidel Castro's only
only known daughter who lives here in
Miami now and she a quote her in the
book she said Raul is the practical
brother and Juanita Castro the the
sister of the Castro brothers also lives
here in Miami since nineteen sixty four
and she told me similar things and she
she talked to me at some length when I
when I when I interviewed her she she
told me about a side of Raul that's
compassionate that's that's caring
that's very human unlike Fidel she said
you know I'm convinced and she said this
on many occasions in public as well she
said I'm convinced that that feed it was
Fidel who caused Raul to become brutal
and and cruel and the executioner that
we you know that that's the other side
of his personality Raul has two very
very different aspects to his
personality he was associated with
hundreds of executions in Cuba in 1959
he he passed his first test with his
brother his I think his most important
test with his brother in and in late
November 1956 in Mexico City a ride
abided in the book and I believe it's
the first time that this story has ever
been told in print Fidel was was
preparing the grandma the yacht that the
revolutionary sailed on from a small
Mexican port it's called took spun and
Veracruz they sailed from took spawns
who oriente and they began the two-year
insurgency that if it
course was victorious in January 59 but
as Fidel was preparing his his men to
board the grandma and set sail he just
before he left Mexico City he ordered
his brother to execute a fellow Cuban
this was another Cuban revolutionary of
the 26 of July movements their movement
and Fidel as he so often does as he has
done hundreds or thousands of times over
the years Fidel lost confidence in this
person I don't know the man's name I've
never been able to determine his name
but Fidel felt that this man was going
to betray him that he would that he
could know Fidel could no longer have
confidence in him a fellow Cuban who
were trained with them and Fidel ordered
Raul to execute him Raul in cold blood
with premeditation did exactly that he
murdered this man in cold blood in
Mexico City he got in a car with another
with another Cuban and they started
driving fast at after dark on the
mountainous winding Mexican roads from
Mexico City that the long long way to to
expand on the Gulf Coast and as they're
driving along in the middle of the night
in in the dark and on these winding
mountain roads there was a Mexican
campesino walking along the side of the
road and probably it was an accident
maybe not Raul ran him down and kept
going never never went back to see if
the man might have survived or if the
man needed to medical care Raul ran him
down and kept going to expand a Mexican
reporter heard me talk to the other day
and I think there's going to be a pretty
big story about about these incidents in
in reformer reform of the one of the
leading mexico city dailies I think
maybe as early as tomorrow but this
these stories have never been told
before I believe and I write in the book
that this was Raul's test Fidel was like
a mafia test or you know of like these
savage gangs you've got to commit
heinous acts of violence in order to
prove your your revolutionary
credentials your revolutionary commit
and ferocity and Raul had had never done
anything like that Raul had never until
then until those murders in Mexico City
and on the highway he had never had
never been involved as far as I can
determine it any kind of violence Fidel
had been involved in all kinds of
violence prior to that he had been
implicated and at least implicated
accused of at least four murders when he
was a university student in Havana he
was he participated in in the Bogota so
in Colombia in april of nineteen forty
eight when he was a twenty-year-old
university student i used to ask my
students at george 10 i would i would
say i would begin telling them about the
de bogota so in april of 48 a colombian
populist leader was was assassinated and
Colombians rushed into the streets and
multitudes and began burning everything
in sight and looting pillaging thousands
of people were injured or killed Fidel
was there and I always used to ask my
students what would you have done if you
were there in Bogota you hear you are a
student at a foreign student in a
strange country and the capital city
erupts in horrendous horrendous
paroxysms of violence I never had one at
Georgetown who said well I would have
gone out into the streets and I would
have I would have joined those people in
the riots it's that's exactly what Fidel
did this 20 year old foreigner in a
strange country that he didn't know he
was out in the streets immediately
there's there's there's this gene in him
perhaps for violence and he the moth to
the flame he had to be out there
experiencing the violence himself he
tells his up by his own accounts soon
very soon he was he armed himself he was
able to get a rifle and other and other
weapons and he was out in the streets
trying to provide a leadership role 20
years old a Cuban in Colombia trying to
provide a leadership role to mobs of
rioting Colombians he's been like that
all his life he's essentially still like
that today but Raul had nothing
my dad in his past until he until he
committed that violence in Mexico and
that was his test he passed the test at
the end of the voyage on the way to to
oriente on the GRANDMONT Raul was given
his first command by Fidel and and soon
Raul up in the Sierra in the Sierra of
oriente Raul was proving his mettle as
one of the cruelest toughest harshest
revolutionaries infidels entourage many
many executions I write about I write
about several of them some of them i
write about from using Raul's own
descriptions of them these are not these
are not mysterious they're you know
they're they're not from Z classified
CIA records some of them are from
Raoul's own descriptions he became he
became one of the most violent men
infidels entourage and proved himself
and in that manner soon became in 1959
the the defense minister a man a gorilla
who knew them both very very well
described Raul and Che Guevara and he
said in those days in 1959 they used to
compete with each other to see who could
who can who could commit the most who
could perform or commit or order the
most executions of Batista followers
what if what if raul should die first
Fidel is fidelis 78 or 79 he's
officially 79 years old he's he's
clearly clearly declining both
physically and I think cognitively I
think his physical and cognitive health
and abilities are all increasingly
impaired he's been falling down and
breaking bones on camera he's been
fainting and passing out and staggering
and in meetings one-on-one meetings I've
talked to many people who have been in
such meetings he he he becomes at least
momentarily incoherent he gets unfocused
he loses that his train of thought he's
he's suffering I think from some serious
life-threatening physical illness and
maybe from early stages of some kind of
dementia I can't be sure
these but his but it's public behavior
over the last few years seems to suggest
that but what if a blood of Raoul dies
first rose four or five years younger
and Raul has been a lifelong a lifelong
heavy drinker he started drinking as a
young man as a teenager heavily drinking
when he was about 15 or 16 and has never
really stopped and by all accounts he's
an alcoholic an unreformed alcoholic and
alcoholic who continues to drink
excessively doing damage he's doing
damage to vital parts if he should die
first is Mike it's my belief that the
Cuban Revolution will be hanging by a
thread it will be just about impossible
I think for an impaired elderly Fidel to
keep it going very much longer without
Raul this is one of the main themes of
the book Raul has been the only truly
essential man in this revolution after
fidel Raul has been truly truly
essential Fidel could I believe could
never have endured have lasted in power
all these years without his brother
loyally maintaining the control of the
Armed Forces any other man running the
armed forces might have conducted a coup
if raul dies first whoever runs the
Armed Forces might be tempted to to
mount a coup it's pretty cut it used to
be pretty common practice in Latin
America in all these years of the Castro
brothers has never been a hint of real
military unrest there's never been a a
palace coup Iran or a colonels revolt or
a quite a Palazzo or an attempted golpe
there's never been even a credible
report or during all of these years of
anything like that it's because Raul has
maintained such effective control of the
Armed Forces he's indispensable in my
opinion a Cuban a Cuban intelligence
officer who lives here told me the
following it said I think it's a
wonderful metaphor and i use it i use it
in one of the first pages of the book if
you if you consider if you can think of
the Cuban Revolution
as an extraordinary theatrical dramatic
event ongoing dramatic event then you
must think of Fidel as the director and
you must think of Raoul as the producer
and neither could have done it without
the other Fidel the director is the
creative genius the visionary love him
or hate him the creative genius the
visionary who looks ahead who plans
great global strategies whoo-hoo under
whose whose leadership Cuba was a global
power for many many years under Fidel
the visionary you know he was dreaming
and constantly coming up with ideas and
plans but he's impractical and he's
utterly totally disorganized it was Raul
who provided all of the organizational
strength and capacity it was Raul the
producer who made sure that the planes
had fuel and the troops had food rations
and that and that things happened on
time Raul has been described was
described by an East Room and
intelligence chief as a Prussian he
meant it as a compliment he said you
know there aren't very many Prussians in
Cuba but Raul he said I got used to
dealing with many many different Cubans
and Raul was the only one it was always
right on time Raul was always was always
precise and organized we thought of him
like oppression I think all of this is I
think all of this is accurate and I I
feel that that biographies of Fidel
Castro they're quite a few in many
languages I feel that those biographies
and all the standard histories of the
Cuban Revolution have neglected perhaps
the most important factor in this and
the success of this revolution after
fidel himself and that's Raul Raul has
been satisfied all these years to be in
the background he he has accepted the
role that Fidel cast in min to continue
using the theatrical metaphor he's been
content playing a subsidy
re-roll being in the background being
off stage or in the wings he's he rarely
does interviews he rarely meets with the
Foreign Press he he doesn't engage in
foreign policy very very little in
foreign policy making he's modest he he
lives quietly and he apparently has a
real passion interest in his family and
in his friends and in colleagues he he
has had mentors he has had friends and
colleagues unlike Fidel Raul is not
emotionally and psychologically some
strange isolated entity Fidel describes
himself that way and I think I think
it's right I think he is just an
extraordinary extraordinary one in ten
million kind of kind of psychological
entity Raul is very human he's very down
to earth his sister and Fidel's daughter
described him that way and many many
others have described him to me that way
former colleagues of his former friends
of his from from his from his youth and
and many many others who have known him
over the years have described him that
way so what if what if raul does not die
first what if Adele does first I don't
know it's those things are impossible to
predict but if you if you if you believe
as I do that Fidel at 78 or 79 is
seriously seriously ill let's say Raul
dies let's say that Fidel dies first I
don't think that there's any leader or
combination of leaders in Cuba who could
challenge Raul for the succession there
are no civilians in the Communist Party
or the mass the popular or mass
organizations there are no civilians
anywhere in the in the apparatus of the
of the dictatorship who could who could
rally enough raw power to challenge Raul
and the generals you see Raul controls
the army the Armed Forces and all of the
top generals are close close associates
of his the most ranking the
senior generals have been with Raul for
for as long as 47 48 49 years some of
them joined Raul when he was up in the
hills as early as 19 57 and 58 it's a
long long time we're going on 50 years
that these men have worked very very
closely with Raul and I think they're
going to stay with Raul I think that
they will want him to to succeed in both
senses of the word to succeed Fidel and
to succeed as Cuba's leader after fidel
how long he can last is anyone's guess
and I I don't try to make a prediction
about that because and I I I explain why
I'm reluctant to make a prediction about
that Raul is lacking in so many of the
extraordinary leadership qualities of
Fidel Raul hates to give speeches and
when he before he gives an important
speech he rehearses and prepares and he
tries to bring his voice down a level or
two he tries to sound you know more
Basso profundo he's but he's oh he's
awkward in public speaking he's awkward
in with win and mass communications
chegg avarra observed this very very
early in 1960 che guevara told a
visiting French intellectual he said you
know I love Raoul he said but you know
we have to admit that Raoul just does
not have direct contact with the masses
that's Fidel Fidel plays that part so
Raul is just doesn't have that ability
he can't communicate the way Fidel can
he he's not an intellectual if anything
he's an anti-intellectual fidelis an
intellectual for a fidelis a voracious
reader if any one of us went to Cuban
and had the misfortune of being alone
with Fidel for an hour or two he he
would charm us he would overwhelm us
with his knowledge of almost any subject
that came up it partly because it's
because he has a photographic memory he
he came out he memorizes vast vast
quantities of information he's truly
exceptional in his intellect truly
exceptional I think on
you test he'd be off the top of the
charts I'll be done in a second he so
he's not an intellectual he does not
really have much of an intellectual life
he doesn't read very much what he does
read is fairly simple stuff he can't
communicate to effectively he's not
loved by the Cuban people Fidel isn't
loved by very many Cubans anymore but
Raul is feared and hated by by lots and
lots of Cubans because he's always been
seen as the hard the tough the ruthless
and the crude of the Castro brothers and
there's one more thing and it could
prove to be the most important and and
then I'm going to stop Raul has
absolutely no experience independent
experience in managing crises every
crisis since moncada in july of 1953
every crisis that the Catholic astros
and their movement have faced their
government their communist party every
crisis Fidel managed personally micro
managed personally down to every detail
from the Bay of Pigs to the missile
crisis to you know just fast-forwarding
up to a few years ago to the elÿon to
the elÿon affair Fidel was managing
every move of that of that eliana fair
now why is this important Raul has no
experience as a crisis manager Fidel
just netted never let him do it how will
Raul manage his first crisis after fidel
will Raul get drunk when he sees the
crisis coming and be unable be
incapacitated be unable to deal with it
rationally will he and which Raul would
come forth let's say he's sober in that
first crisis which Raul would be most
likely to come forth the ruthless cruel
Raul or the compassionate Raul and I'll
stop there thank you so much
I've got to acknowledge the gentleman
behind you cuz he had his hand up a
moment just what did they ask a question
when you say that Fidel is a genius and
he's all these good things what's his
emotional makeup emotionally well you
know I I think that to call him a
narcissist would hardly be an
exaggeration I don't you know I'm not a
psychologist and I I don't want to get
into all you know so didn't try to do
that but it did the CIA do studies about
the psyche the psychiatric and
psychological aspect of the leaders sure
narcissism would not certainly not be an
exaggeration I mean he's he kind of it
kind of defines narcissism look up get
any book on or diagnosis of narcissism
and look at all of the characteristics
Fidel scores a hundred some of his some
is some of his behavior as a young man I
perhaps could be fairly described as
sociopathic some of those some of those
murders or attempted murders that I
described in the book some of the some
of the violence that he took pardon in
Bogota it was it was beyond beyond what
most of most all of us would ever
consider to be normal he's a he's an
island psychologically he's an island
which you know I which was why I was
talking about no mentor no boss personal
sovereignty and personal autonomy and
personal independence have have
motivated him since childhood I I tell
you in the book of it why I think why I
think he developed that way and what
happened to him in childhood to to come
Helen to push him in that direction sir
ya january 59 in santiago de cuba
interviewed raw veggie along with
Philomena one was it what month January
it was about the third or fourth of
January Fidel had already left town gone
on his two and we're at the airport but
I was concerned about certain things in
the Caribbean and I
him and he answered very well and of
course he was next to his companion bill
Aminu whatever gilma villains been yeah
and she answered a lot too yes she
interjected yes and when I got to Havana
to file my story I was doing AP and
several others and he the the only thing
interesting the editor there was he had
a pigtail was her i can underscore this
front overall had a big deal raed he had
if he had that and so in this was a big
thing you know wearing the pigtail he
wore that was a late late that year yeah
but he was very forthcoming i was very
impressed although the comments in
havana at the time was well you know
he's yeah i mean i wrote there were
rumors about that sort of thing in those
days so the wig risk you know but he the
story where he was out space there were
a few other American or English speaking
reporters who who interviewed him in in
late 58 and early 59 and they they
generally had negative impressions of
him and and very and very positive
impressions of a Vilma it was good very
forthcoming he's very complicated yeah I
didn't go into his eye collage I guess
done could you go into a little bit
about the Ochoa trial and you mentioned
that there were you mentioned there's
been no sign of any rebellion or
anything else and your cho a trial sort
of surface some rumors of that to that
effect well you know there are there are
a lot of different views of the ocho Art
Fair everybody I guess remembers the
general who was executed in in the
summer of nineteen eighty-nine a chola
was the most popular decorated effective
general in the in the Cuban armed forces
which just by definition made him a
potential threat to Fidel the ocho ocho
affair erupted within 10 days of
tiananmen square in beijing and I think
that's the context in which everybody
should be thinking of what happened to
general
it was a the summer of nineteen
eighty-nine was the time when the
Eastern European communist regimes were
hemorrhaging and soon would begin to
break up but Berlin Wall came down in
November of 1989 Soviet Union itself was
beginning you know the beginning to
crack break and Fidel Castro the
political prodigy the genius that he is
he knew that Cuba could not that his
regime could not withstand all of those
things that were happening and happening
in the other communist countries and he
I have a whole chapter that that really
that goes into this but I think he had
been worried about Ochoa for a long time
he he feared that Ochoa was not a
hundred percent reliable they put bugs
the Cuban intelligence service put bugs
and taps on Ochoa and they caught him
saying compromising things probably in
his own the privacy of his own home or
office but they caught him saying
compromising things one of them was he
was talking to a couple of others about
you know maybe perhaps even jokingly we
ought to think about defecting we ought
to do what general del pino did a couple
of years ago we ought to maybe we ought
to do what he did and defect to the US
and once once they all got a transcript
of that show was fate was sealed and
then and then what Fidel had to do was
to create a to create a pretext for
executing the most popular effective
General in his armed forces so he
dreamed up the drug trafficking charges
that's that's
rebellion or a plot I don't believe I
don't believe so I don't believe it ever
got to that I don't think that Ochoa was
plotting actively plotting against Fidel
I think as I say in the book and I i
quote i quote a very very high-level
official from the government a defector
who says that Fidel Fidel just no longer
trusted Ochoa because owed showa had
lost respect for Fidel and Fidel knew
that that was enough he has survived for
all these years in power because he
smells he smells the earliest traces of
opposition or dissent and he acts with
brutally and swiftly talking about role
at the beginning of the revolution fee
the rahul used to go around with a
ponytail like it was pointed out has no
beard because he couldn't grow one and
there was the rumor that he was
effeminate then he married wilma and
apparently he there's rumors that be
sighs his alcoholism his sexual life is
a little bit complicated can you expound
a little bit about his family does he
have two three families like Fidel well
I don't I don't discuss his sexual
preferences all of us are aware that
there have been such rumors but I don't
discuss those I just chose not to and
I'm not sure that that they're
significant what I do discuss is Raul's
paternity there's a very very good
chance that Fidel and Raul have
different fathers different biological
fathers I do discuss that in some in
some detail Raul's biological father may
very well be a man named felipe or el
chino mirabal el chino Miravalle people
talk about Raul having you know looking
a little chinito himself he's very very
different physically from
from Fidel you know he's a lot shorter
his facial features are very different
and all of the things that I've said
about his character his personality
everything about him seems to be
different from Fidel and if you look at
their other brother Ramon they have the
tube Radel and Raul have one other
brother Ramon Ramon is the spitting
image of Fidel the spitting image of
Fidel he's tall like Fidel and has
features just very similar to Fidel so
there's I I explained in the book and
you know I actually dug up some
additional evidence on this that I that
I found to be to contribute to
contribute even more to the you know to
this possibility that they have
different fathers if you if you see the
book I found I found in hidden away in
old old Cuban records a reference that
Raul made to that that I think
contributes to the to this to this
despair a distinct possibility but in
the end I say in the book why is it
significant maybe they do and maybe they
don't have the same biological father if
it's significant at all it's because we
once we're all trying to understand what
are their differences well how are they
similar in how are they dissimilar and
how that how Mike those things impact on
a on a successor regime yes and quick
one side what were you going to title
your book had you not titled it this way
number one number two who is Ramona what
does he do I was my titled my working
title when I sold the book but I sold
the book that the title was my brother's
keeper and I I fought to keep it but
anyway here we are it's after fidel one
of the I think one of the disadvantages
of my brother's keeper is it doesn't
translate into Spanish I don't know how
you say it in Spanish it just doesn't
translate there's there's no equivalent
is there in Spanish what was the other
question who's Ramona what is he doing
Ramon is two years eighteen months two
years older than Fidel and he never had
any interest in politics he did not join
his brothers up in the mountains he did
not train with them at moncada grandma
or he did not go up into the hills and
Fidel resented him for that
uh he's he's alive and he's he's in
Havana he spent many years when he was
younger working in agriculture working
on he ran a state farm Fidel gave him a
state farm to run but I think he's
retired now Jerry fine I'm using an
ironic that perónism has been able to
survive without juan perón and Evita
they host Lisa Lisa party is
institutionalized something whereas you
seem to be saying that without Raul and
Fidel afterwards we will look back and
seeing that Cuban communism failed to be
institutionalized was another failure
and so therefore what comes next is it
the army is it a socialist democracy or
is it army led communism you know maybe
I'm going to do another book and and get
into that in this book I don't Jerry I
don't go that far out into the future
but I mean just just to give you a brief
sense of how I feel about it I do think
there will be some similarities i do
think that after fidel and after all
there will be there will be some feed at
least organized fidel eastham movement I
think there's a very good chance of that
but but the revolution as we know it is
is not going to is not going to last too
much longer after after these brothers I
I seriously doubt that in the back Fidel
have on Chavez power Fidel is talking to
Chavez all the time from what I
understand they're on the phone fidelis
mentoring and advising Chavez regularly
Fidel was just there in in Venezuela in
June just a few months ago and they have
met personally and conferred personally
at least a dozen times that we know of
and probably many many other times
they're there have probably been secret
flights of one or the other to the other
country on many occasions that we don't
know about Chavez I've spent time with
as I spend a few hours with him three
years ago on the on the patio of his of
the presidential palace in Caracas
miraflores we were needed me I've never
been close to Fidel I mean he's in any
sense I've never been never been need a
knee with him or even in the same room
with him but I did have that chance with
Chavez and I was able to you know assess
him in person and I can tell you he's no
Fidel Castro he does not have the
extraordinary and select the the
extraordinary imagination the charisma
he doesn't have the cloth the
extraordinary qualities of Fidel but as
long as he has Fidel on the phone with
him every day and he has all that oil
wealth he's got billions of dollars he's
is he's a very very potent force in
Latin America today Chavez is and as
long as Fidel is able to keep talking to
him and advising him he's going to he's
going to be formidable yes what about
Camilla one days is he such an
insignificant member of the party do you
mean romeoville de cámara Mirabel dad's
the former the former Minister of
Interior two times he served for two
different periods as Minister of
Interior running all of the security and
intelligence services a very good very
good source of mine who was in who was
in rauls entourage told me the following
he said when when Raul was able to get
Ramiro Valdez fired in 1985 Sofia at the
end of his second tour interior minister
Raul completely defeated Ramiro Ramiro
was summoned to raul's office I tell the
story in the book Raul had been trying
to persuade Fidel for a long time to get
rid of Ramiro Romero was perhaps over
the years and this that's why your
question is is such a good one Romero
was perhaps the nearest thing to a
threat to Rowell in this in the line of
succession a gorilla going back to the
earliest days and Raul had been trying
for a long time to get
to remove him and he finally persuaded
Fidel in 1985 to get rid of Romero and
Fidel said this is this is so typical of
Fidel he said all right all right Raul
you will do it he said you gotta tellin
so Raul summoned Ramiro Valdez this is
another really tough brutal
revolutionary he summoned rahi summoned
Ramiro Valdez to his office at the
Defense Ministry and Raul had his
bodyguard a really really powerful tough
bodyguard hide in the private bathroom
right behind his desk in the ministry in
his office just in case Ramiro Valdez
got violent so Raul delivered the bad
news and if Ramiro Valdez had gotten
really crazy the guard would have come
out and you know Ramiro didn't have a
chance I think I think that's the end of
the story I don't think Ramiro will ever
pose a challenge to Raul Raul Raul has
enjoys the loyalty of all of those two
and three-star generals not Ramiro
Adriana this is adriana bosch right and
steer a second plan I mean beside role
as an heir given all we know about his
health and how close they are in age how
you know intelligent fidelis in planning
political alternatives do you know if
there is a second plan I think there is
not it's because in my interpretation it
is because there has never been a third
man it was never a third man in the 60s
or 70s or at any time there is no third
man now why because each of the Castro
brothers refuses to have someone who
would be could play that role a man who
knew them both extremely well told me he
said you know each of the Castro
brothers is very
very dangerous in his own right but if
they're together it's a danger that's
extraordinary no I don't think there's
any I don't think there's any other plan
I want to get somebody else in the back
ailing Fidel was it is there any
mechanism do you think it's likely that
the role could come to power before
Fidel passes and how would that could
that happen well that there is a that
would be completely consistent with the
Cuban Communist Constitution Raul Raul
is second in line in the you know in all
of the positions in the party the state
the government and the Constitution says
that in the absence or incapacitation of
the President the Vice President would
you know would would fill in and that's
Raul but that begs but that begs the
question in one sense when will Raul be
able to walk into Fidel's office or
bedroom and say ed mano he doesn't call
him at a mano he doesn't call him
brother calls him chief as as most of
the other Cuban leaders do jefe lo
siento mucho um but the time has come
you've you've made this revolution and
now it's time now it's time you have to
rest we're going to ask you now to rest
and we're going to make some decisions
Raul is going to have to do that one of
these days it's going to be very hard
for him see how good my how good my
former students are you sir yes there
are some rumors about a raul castro has
a colon cancer you think that it is it
is true this I have not heard this I
have not heard I tell it I tell an
interesting I think a humorous little
story in the book about one time back in
the early 90s Raul had been out of sight
out of public view for quite a while and
he you know and the rumors rumors like
that became very commonplace and he
decided he had to come out and make a
public appearance
and he has he has a sense of humor Fidel
has no sense of humor you know Fidel
will crack some awful joke and you know
expect everybody to laugh and you know
it here if you're in his entourage you
do laughs and you better laugh but Raul
has a real sense of humor and and a
self-deprecating sense of humor Fidel
isn't it self-deprecation is absolutely
impossible for Fidel but Raul it is
possible for Raul Raul when he came out
and he did this press conference he said
you know he said to the Cuban reporter
he said you know he said all these
rumors that I'm dead you know he said
innocent as far as they think that I'd
been put on ice that I'm in a freezer
that I'm that I'm dead dead in a freezer
someplace yes in Eastern Europe we have
a number of models of post-communist
transition do you think any of those
bear any relation or can serve as a
potential trajectory for what's going to
happen in Cuba in a post-communist
transition or do you think Cuba is going
to be so completely different from any
of the experiences of Eastern Europe
well you know we hope we all hope that
the transition could be like the one in
the Czech Republic or hungry or even
Poland not like the one in Romania you
know whether protracted violent ones in
other countries we we hope that the
transition will not be like Nicaragua
because the transition there is still
going on Cuba is unique and Cuba is
different I I hesitate to try to apply
any of those models even the Soviet
Union to the Cuba case because there was
no there was no marxist-leninist leader
after Lenin a comparable to Fidel Castro
only Lennon there's no there was no
other marxist-leninist leader comparable
to Fidel Fidel was it Fidel came to
power without the sub without the sort
of the red army without Soviet tanks
without the help of the Communist Party
he came to power as a revolutionary as a
nationalist as a radical as a very very
appealing love him or hate him is like
he
saying in 1959 Cubans loved him
overwhelmingly so i think i think the
model is very different and i think the
military the military is the strongest
institution the most influential the
most the best-managed it's also the only
real meritocracy among institutions on
the island the nearest thing to a true
meritocracy and it's also the richest
institution on the island so I think I
don't think those other models will then
will necessarily apply the gentleman in
the back how do you see Cuban Chinese
relations developing i would expect them
to to continue developing closely
especially especially as raul gains more
and more influence over decision-making
that they'd like to have chinese
investment and I as I said earlier I
think Raul is very attractive to the
Chinese political and economic model so
yeah I should think that there would be
more but you know as in terms of I'm not
a China specialist but in terms of
economic opportunity for China Cuba is a
pretty small pretty small potato you
know not like Brazil or Argentina yeah
it's one it's it's it's 11 million
Brazil as 190 million uh sir given
Fidel's intellect did Fidel necessarily
choose Chavez no Chavez kind of chose
Fidel and what's roles position and all
that I wish I could tell you about and
you know respond to that first question
I wish I knew Chavez clearly has been
attracted to Cuban the Cuban Revolution
for a long long time what the
circumstances where I just don't know
Raul and Chavez I don't I don't know
that they have a personal relationship
of any of any of any significance so
after fidel that hold that whole switch
that whole relationship could
dramatically change i I just don't
imagine Raul being on the phone all the
time with
with who go the way fidelis what does a
Larkin fit into this combination of
personalities that you have talked about
I think our cone is insignificant I I
apologize if he if he hears or sees this
but I think he's insignificant I think
Raul holds him more a lesson in contempt
yes I think Carlos la que on the other
hand would hey I think la he on the
other hand would have a much better
chance of staying on hey one I didn't
see you there until right now sorry you
also mentioned you've joked about aldana
making a comeback in rien past speeches
is that still a possibility I wouldn't
rule that out yeah I that's a wild card
that I think could be could be one that
US policymakers ought to be thinking
about carlos saldanha was one of the
only high level Cuban leaders in the
last 40 or 50 45 years who was equally
close to each of the Castro brothers um
and he was he was fired in the end by by
Fidel over Raul's objections because he
was advocating too much internal
economic reform and he was he was sent
into home exile but he's still on the
island he's he's probably in his submit
60s I have I have speculated publicly
that he could after fidel he could
command after Raul this is the third man
thing going I don't think he's a third
man but here's here's a third man kind
of scenario he could just it's
conceivable that he could be Cuba's dung
shopping he's he's an intern he's an
internal disgrace he has no political
role he was demoted and and sent into
internal exile by Fidel but Raul still
likes and what if what if the dell dies
next week and Raul text takes over I
could easily imagine Raul bringing
aldana back to Havana and just the way
done shopping was brought back and then
I could imagine after row
cool at this very very clever fellow
aldana could maybe he could be the third
man audrianna good that's a good
question thanks I didn't didn't see you
there yes love them or hate them as you
say Fidel has done a masterful job at
manipulating Cuban US policy what can we
expect from a rules administration in
that room yeah I I knew we'd get there I
do address that in the last chapter and
let me just put it out it as I do in the
book as a hypothetical I don't argue
this I don't recommend it I don't even
know if it's likely but it's a
hypothetical what if raul takes power
after fidel and what if what if all of
these sources of mine are right that
he's the practical brother the flexible
brother the pragmatic brother what if he
what if he decides that he must have
good relations with the united states in
order in order to stabilize his regime
and protect his regime i think that
perhaps he would not have the same blood
antipathy toward the United States that
Fidel does what if raul did just two or
three things here they are what if he
sent emissaries to Washington to say
look to lead to be a visceral what any
future administration look we want this
to be over this has been too long this
estrangement between our countries and
our peoples we want to cooperate with
the United States and every way
conceivable in counterterrorism we're
going to share our intelligence what
everything we have in our intelligence
files on al-qaeda on international
terrorism we're going to share with you
and we want to start working with CIA
FBI Homeland Security on
counterterrorism what are they going to
say in Washington to that they're going
to say no that's ridiculous we wouldn't
hear of it what if Raul said in the next
breath through an emissary we
we no longer want Havana to be a safe
haven a sanctuary for international
criminals and terrorists we're going to
return her aina to you he's the only
international terrorist on the FBI ten
most wanted list a Puerto Rican
terrorists who conducted terrorism
violence in the United States with Cuban
support years ago he's living in he's
living in juba he has safe haven or
sanctuary there are there are there are
criminals convicted in US courts who
fled to Cuba convicted of capital crimes
who are who are fugitives protected in
Cuba what if raul return to all of them
what if he did just those two things
counterterrorism and and those those
gestures would current policy be
sustainable it's this is a hypothetical
would the current policy of estrangement
with Cuba be sustainable my point is
this is a hypothetical but if raul took
just a few initiatives and there were
two or three others four or five others
you all of us could think of that Raul
could do unilaterally to in with the
objective of improving relations with
the United States all of them are things
that Fidel would never under any
circumstances do but route it's possible
that Raul would there's no way Fidel
would have ever been receptive to
overtures by Kennedy Nixon or Kissinger
john i believe that i believe that i
think the anti-americanism is in his is
in his blood it's it's in him it's
within him it's part of him i think it's
it's been part of him since the late
1940s when he was a university student i
don't think he's ever wanted to have
good relations with the United States
you know the the last American
ambassador in Havana was Philip on Sal
and he was Eisenhower's ambassador he he
left just when we broke relations in
January of 1961 and bone Sal and his
book year many many years ago he said
you know he said I tried and tried and
tried more than anything I wanted to
develop good clothes real
lations a good working relationship with
the Cuban Revolution and the Eisenhower
administration wanted to do that too he
said but eventually I finally concluded
that Fidel would never have good
relations with the United States because
to do that would threaten his absolute
control in Cuba if the Americans had any
influence at all in Cuba it would
threaten his absolute control now in the
book I don you've read it I I do i do
make some confessions I didn't come to
that conclusion for quite a few years as
a CIA analyst I didn't come to that
conclusion until the mid-1970s and I I
participated as a middle-ranking
intelligence officer in the afford
Kissinger efforts at negotiating a
rapprochement with Cuba I participated
as an intelligence advisor in those in
those talks and at that time I believed
that Fidel would would want to have
better relations with the United States
but I was wrong he did not want better
relations with the United States he
placed a much higher priority on
revolutionary internationalism on
supporting Puerto Rican terrorists on
sending Cuban troops to Angola and in
many other countries so don my view my
view totally changed after after 1975
there's a young lady back here known
again sublime to the ridiculous but I
used to work for CNN and there was a CNN
cameraman there who told me a story that
I'd hoped you might confirm he had gone
to Havana for an interview with Castro
and Castro himself who you said has no
sense of humor told him a story that to
this day I don't find credible and the
story was that according to Castro he
had been hunting with Khrushchev and
they I don't know who it was that picked
it but it was a green that was renowned
for deers mating and they Khrushchev and
Castro or a different sides of this
green and Castro was relating with
relish how he could have killed
Khrushchev I just found that bizarre and
I wondered if you had ever heard that
story yeah this story is is pretty
accurate
a film that Estella Bravo did a you know
a film that I don't know if it meet
people here have seen very one-sided
film but he does have an interview with
you they'll I'm Fedele himself tells
that story of having thought of how
about that so it is it is true hmm but
that was a really good shot Fidel I tell
a lot I tell some stories in the book
and I I leave I leave this mostly to the
reader's imagination but I tell three or
four or five stories about how Fidel his
preference always has been to fire from
a distance like a sniper not to get in
hand-to-hand kind of kind of rough and
tumble it's a fire from a distance when
he was in the Sierra Maestra he always
his favorite weapon was a rifle with a
telescopic telescopic sight and he was
always he always fired from a pretty
safe distance and he did the same on a
number of other occasions it's I think
it's part of a psychology and I think
it's very revealing that that that's
that's his preference um we have time
for just one last question I'm sold I'm
happy to stay on if anybody wants would
like me to sign their book I'd be happy
this down is there somebody who hasn't
asked a question who who would like to
be the last yes I don't know many of the
names that you're mentioning but is they
are they all of this same generation is
there a generational succession problem
that is that none of this touches the 10
years from now where any where is it all
going that's a good question but it's
the leadership is a gerontocracy with
only a few exceptions it's it's an it's
an old to elderly leadership with only a
few exceptions Carlos LaHaye we've
mentioned he's the sort of the economic
Prince I wouldn't call him an economic
czar cuz there's only one person who can
bizarre in Cuba but La Haye is kind of
an economical in economic policy fidelis
78 or 79 Raul is five years younger many
of the all of the top generals are in
their upper 60s or 70s
these the the lower two star 1 star
generals are mostly in their in their
60s and and many of the other leaders
are called East OD Coast their
historical figures because they go all
the way back their careers can be traced
back to the struggles of the 1950s Fidel
and Raul trust those older men and they
don't trust younger people I keep saying
men and I and please don't consider
consider this in any way arbitrary I
mean it exactly that way there simply
are no women in this revolution with any
political significance today or ever
before woman and she had a lot of power
in the government she had personal
influence with Fidel but no power I
don't think she had any power I think
she I think she was a kind of secretary
an aide-de-camp for Fidel I don't think
she ever made a decision I don't think I
doubt that she ever recommended a major
decision to him is that it oh we or do
we have time for one more or what
books are available at the counter uh